what I want to do in this video is
tackle a problem that would be
considered pretty difficult for most
first-year physics students and you
frankly probably wouldn't be expected to
solve a problem like this in most
first-year physics class or if you're in
an advanced or honors class you might be
expected or it might be a bonus problem
but it's an interesting type of problem
because what we're going to do is we're
going to have we're going to launch a
projectile on an incline so maybe we're
on the side of a hill so that's so it's
a hill let me do it in green so let's
say we're on the side of a hill like
this and let's say that we know the
inclination of the hill the hills
inclination is 30 degrees is 30 degrees
off the horizontal so this is the
horizontal right over here so that is
the inclination of the hill and then we
are going to launch a projectile we are
going to launch a projectile at 10
meters per second we're going to launch
it at 10 meters per second and the angle
with the hill is 15 degrees so at a 15
degree angle with the hill and the
reason why this is more difficult than
the traditional projectile motion
problems is well we can think about it
the projectile is going to be launched
and it is going to eventually land at
some point on the hill but we can't do
this the simple figure out how long it's
in the air using it's vertical velocity
because we don't know what the vertical
displacement for this thing is going to
be unless we know how far down how far
down the hill it lands because the
further the further down the hill and
lands the higher the vertical
displacement so we have to think about
both the the horizontal and the vertical
displacement at the same time and we'll
as we walk through this you'll see how
that can be done so in the so I guess
the first thing that we really would
always want to do whenever you want to
try to find solve this type of problem
is break up our velocity into both the
horizontal and vertical components so
the vertical component of our velocity
the vertical component of our velocity
is going to be the magnitude of a lot of
our velocity of our total velocity 10
meters per second times and be very
careful here not the sine of 15 degrees
but the sine of
the angle with the horizontal so times
the sine of 45 degrees times the sine of
45 degrees and I go into a lot more
detail in previous videos for the sake
of time I won't go into it but it really
just comes from sohcahtoa if we if we
were to draw the vertical component it
would look like this it would look like
this this is the angle the sine of 45
degrees is equal to the opposite over
the hypotenuse or the hypotenuse times
the sine of 45 degrees is equal to the
vertical component that's where it's
coming from let me get rid of some of
the stuff I just drew just so it makes
it a little bit cleaner and the
horizontal component the horizontal
component of our velocity is going to be
by the same logic 10 cosine of 45
degrees now let's think about what the
horizontal displacement is going to be
the horizontal displacement and I'm just
going to go straight to the formula that
we derived in the last few videos the
horizontal displacement is going to be
our initial [ __ ] sorry let's do the
vertical displacement the vertical
displacement I could have done the
horizontal displacement first but the
vertical displacement is going to be our
initial vertical velocity which we know
as 10 sine of 45 degrees and by the way
let's we could just solve that right now
what is the sine of 45 degrees sine of
45 degrees is square root of 2 over 2
cosine of 45 degrees is also square root
of 2 over 2 so both of these values 10
times square root of 2 over 2 is 5
square roots of 2 so this whole thing
right over here is 5 square roots of 2
meters per second meters per second
that's our vertical velocity and our
horizontal velocity is also our
horizontal velocity is also 5 square
roots of 2 meters per second so that
simplifies things a little bit but
anyway we were talking about our
vertical displacement our vertical
displacement is going to be our initial
vertical velocity 5 square roots of 2
times our change in time times our
change in time plus plus the
acceleration
and plus the acceleration well we know
the acceleration is it's negative 9.8
m/s^2 something right minus 9.8 I'm not
going to write the unit's here so that
we save space x times our change in x
squared times our change in x squared
all of that over 2 we derive this in
several videos especially the last view
where we do these two dimensional
projectile motions so this gives us our
displacement in the Y direction and I
can simplify this a little bit our
displacement in the vertical direction
is equal to is equal to 5 square roots
of 2 times delta T times let me do it
that same times delta T change in time
minus 4.9
minus 4.9 times our change in x squared
times our change in x squared so we know
we have this constraint right over here
and now so this gives us our this gives
us our vertical displacement as a
function of time let's think about our
horizontal displacement as a function of
time our horizontal displacement is
going to be equal to our horizontal
velocity which is 5 square roots of 2
times our change in time times our
change in time now what can we do next
well we have to have some relationship
between our horizontal displacement and
our vertical displacement and that
relationship is going to be given to us
by this incline so wherever we land
let's say this is where we eventually do
end up landing what is going to be our
horizontal and well let's think about
our horizontal and our vertical
displacements and what their
relationship would have to be so this is
where we land then this would be our we
doing the same colors this right here
would be that right there would be my
vertical displacement I would move that
far up and then our and our horizontal
displacement will be this right over
here will be that length right over
there so that is our horizontal
displacement so what is the relationship
between our vertical displacement and
our horizontal displacement and we know
that this angle right
here is 30 degrees so we can use some
basic trigonometry we have a right
triangle we know the opposite side from
the angle we know the adjacent side and
the trig function that uses the opposite
and the adjacent is the tangent function
so we get the tangent the tangent of 30
degrees is going to be equal to is going
to be equal to the magnitude the
magnitude of our vertical displacement
over the magnitude of our horizontal
displacement over the magnitude of our
horizontal displacement and the tangent
of 30 degrees that's the same thing as
the sine of 30 over let me just do it
over here so the tangent of 30 degrees
is the same thing as the sine of 30
degrees over the cosine of 30 degrees
let me do this a little bit neater and
the sine of 30 degrees is 1/2 this is
equal to 1/2 and the cosine of 30
degrees is the square root of 3 over 2
so this is equal to 1/2 times 2 over the
square root of 3 which is equal to 1
over the square root of 3 so we get the
magnitude of our vertical component over
the magnitude of our horizontal
component this is our horizontal
component right over here over our
horizontal component is equal to 1 over
the square root of 3 is equal to 1 over
square root of 3 what's useful about
this is it gives us a relationship
between our horizontal and vertical
component or between our vertical and
our horizontal components and we can use
this constraint right over here to then
to then solve for one of these two and
let me show you how we'll do it
so let's just explicitly write this so
if we if we multiply well let's do it
this way let us cross multiply here
which is really the same thing as
multiplying both sides by the square
root of 3 and the magnitude of our
horizontal component we get we get the
square root of 3 times the magnitude
times the magnitude and both of these
are going to be positive and we know
where well let me just write it this way
times the magnitude of our vertical
component is going to be equal to the
magnitude of our horizontal component
the magnitude of
a horizontal component so right just
just like that so we now have a
relationship between the length of these
two vectors and we can use this
relationship to substitute back into the
constraints that we already have so this
comes the second constraint right over
here let's use this information the
second constraint says that our
horizontal component is going to of our
displacement is equal to 5 square roots
of 2 times our change in time or another
way of thinking about it if we divide
both sides by 5 square roots of 2 we get
our change in time is equal to our
change in time is equal to the
horizontal component the horizontal
component of our displacement divided by
5 square roots of 2 but we also know
that the horizontal component of our
displacement is the square root of 3
times the vertical component of our
displacement and I'm going to get a
little bit here I explicitly wrote the
magnitude notation when we start dealing
with the either just the vertical or the
horizontal component we can I can just
write it like this because it's either
going to be a positive or negative value
and that specifies both the magnitude
and the direction so what I'm going to
do right over here and obviously the way
I've drawn it right over here both of
these are going to be positive values
it's upwards displacement in the
vertical direction so that's positive by
our convention and we're moving to the
right so that's positive also by our
convention so this so I can rewrite I
can rewrite this over here as being
equal to square root of 3 square root of
3 square root of 3 times our vertical
displacement times our vertical
displacement and all that's over five
square roots of two all of that is over
five square roots of two now the whole
reason why I did this is where we this
expression right here can contains this
information contains the ratio between
our vertical displacement and our
horizontal displacement and it also
contains the information of how does the
horizontal displacement how does that
change as a function of time so this our
time is needs to be equal to this so
this is our time as a function of our
vertical displacement now
time is a function of our horizontal
displacement and what we can do is we
can use this constraint with our
original with our original this vertical
displacement as a function of time to
then solve for our vertical displacement
so let's do that let's substitute this
business right here for delta T in this
top in this top equation right over here
so if we do that and I'll write it big
we got our vertical displacement we get
our vertical displacement right over
there is equal to v square root of two
times delta T so it's five square roots
of two delta T is all of this business
over here so five square roots of two
times delta T delta T is square root of
three times our vertical component all
of that really the magnitude of our
vertical component over five square
roots of two so that's that right there
and then oh actually we could look at
this one right over here we can use this
constraint this is just simplified so
that we have minus 4.9 minus 4.9 times
delta T squared so delta T squared is
this quantity squared I'll just write it
out so I don't want to skip too many
steps so delta T once again is the
square root of three times the vertical
component all of that over five square
roots of two squared and now what does
this give us so now we literally have a
quadratic equation with only one
variable so we can solve for this but
let me rewrite it let me simplify it so
we have our vertical component is equal
to now we have a five square root of two
times five squared in the numerator and
one of the denominator they cancel out
so we get the square root of 3 square
root of three times our vertical
component the magnitude of our vertical
component it's actually also specifying
well the magnitude we could say for now
although I'm not using that notation and
then we have this hole it's and then we
have minus 4.9 times this quantity
squared so that's going to be square
root of three squared is three times the
vertical component squared the vertical
component squared and then fought over
five squared which is 25 times two
that's the square root of two squared so
25 times 2 is 50 and so we get if we
were to simplify
this a little bit more let's subtract
this from both sides we get I'll do it
all in one color
zero is equal to the square root of
three minus one minus one times our
vertical component times our vertical
component because if we subtract this
from both sides that's square root of
three times our vertical component minus
one times our vertical component so it's
the square root of three minus one times
our vertical component and then we have
all of this business minus 4.9
times three over 50 over 50 times our
vertical component times our vertical
component squared and lucky for us we
can just factor out one of these S sub
Y's over here one of these vectors and
so we can get and I'll just do that in
place so that I don't well let me just I
don't want to skip too many steps so
this is equal to the square root of
three minus one minus 4.9 let me do it
in that color so let me do it like this
it's equal to it's equal to the square
root of three minus one minus 4.9 times
three over 50 times one of these times
our vertical component and then we
factored one of those vertical
components out so we factored one of
them out so the vertical component of
our displacement could either be so that
we have the product of two things they
equal zero so our vertical displacement
could be zero which is true because at
some point in the path we literally had
zero vertical to play displacement that
was literally where we started but
that's not the answer we're looking for
we're looking for this vertical
displacement so either this is going to
be zero but that's just kind of the
obvious answer or all of this business
is going to be equal to zero but this is
pretty easy to solve for zero over here
so we get we get square root of three
minus one minus 4.9 let me just let me
just calculate all of these things just
so I don't have to keep writing them so
we get the square root of 3 square root
of three minus one is equal to 0.73 two
zero five
so I'll just write 0.732 here so this is
equal to 0.73 - that's that part right
over there and then four point nine four
point nine out of this problems getting
along but this is a well let's pause it
and take a break if you're getting tired
four point nine times 3 divided by 50
divided by 50 is equal to 0.2 9 4 so
minus 0.2 9 4 minus is 0.294 I could put
a zero out front just to make clear
where we are times this times our
vertical component this could also be
equal to zero
either this is 0 or that that is your
when this is zero it gives us the
obvious answer we're more interested in
this to solve for this we can we can add
this to both sides and we get zero point
seven three two is equal to negative
zero point two nine four times the
vertical component we are in the
homestretch we divide both sides by by
this by negative zero point two nine by
oh sorry this will now be positive
almost made a careless mistake after 16
minutes of video so now we divide both
sides by zero point two nine for both
sides by zero point two nine four and we
get our vertical displacement so this I
think a drumroll might be in order so we
have 0.732
and all of this business but I'll just
round it there divided by 0.294 gives us
a vertical displacement of two point if
we round to point five zero meters or
two point four nine meters I should say
so this is equal to this is equal to two
point four nine meters this is exciting
this is equal to two point four nine
meters and now we can figure out the
horizontal displacement pretty easily
because we know that the horizontal
displacement is square root of three
times the vertical displacement so let's
figure that out that's the vertical
displacement let's multiply that times
the square root of three and we get four
point three one meters so we get the
horizontal displacement
the horizontal displacement is equal to
four point three one meters so this is
equal to four point three one meters and
so if you wanted to figure out so we
actually now know the total displacement
in the vertical direction and in the
horizontal direction and I'll leave it
up to you if you wanted to figure out
exactly how far along the hill we
traveled you can just use both of these
values in the Pythagorean theorem to
essentially figure out the hypotenuse of
this right triangle